hello to all thank you for being present
I still have the heavy mission of
keeping you with me just for the cocktail
so I'm sebastien in nyon I'm
pre-sales customer engineers we've been
calling that at google paris for almost
five years now j  i joined google
to sell products around the
search engine for four
years i have been in the google cloud
platform team with a very data focus for
southern europe and then now for
godfather for france and all over the world  hour
I will be accompanied by nicolas auger who
is chief data officer at early bird
and who overall we will explain to you
how to put to music everything that I
am going to present
to you today just to give you a little
context
so I suggest you start  by a
quick history on
storage technologies and then I will
present to you all the google cloud
platform offer in terms of storage why
I say all the offer if we pretend
contains u  n certain number of use cases
and in relation to these use cases
there is an associated technology
I suggest you go over all
of these bricks there and illustrate
it with a cadet with a school case and
we'll end with the great presentation by
nicolas who will explain to you how he
put on the big three with the north spa
with beat them all and all the
bricks
I'm pretty sure you've
already seen this slide maybe some  dozens
of times hundreds of times it depends
on your age but overall
it's not new
I'm going to go to the data in the company we've been
doing it for years
nevertheless there are new cases of  '
usage that is emerging and there is a
problem that is quite recent and
which is becoming more and more
problematic, it is how to manage the
volume of data
and who says large volumes of data
says that there is a significant impact on
two things  on the hit and on the
performance and I was talking about new
cases  of use
we will typically talk about die oti
of connected objects which says millions
of connected objects says millions of
associated data that will have to be managed
we will talk about initiative also
like open data for example we put more
in addition to data available, we
share it and we reuse it and decadent
the
in medical or healthcare
like genomics mean that the
volume the volume of data is exploding day by
day globally we have gone from a mode
where it  there were silos the deal and the
volume was quite controlled a volume of
data that is exponential and that you
have to manage and manage the deal and it has
become a technical challenge for
companies when I talk about
digital transformation like that and
new data new
user cases there is immediately
a case that comes to my mind it is the
case of the airbus defense and space
I think you know this
company and particularly the
geo intelligence branch c  what is their job
is to take satellite photos of the
earth and sell them to customers be to
be they are leaders on the market they have
been around for more than thirty years
and therefore it is a
colossal volume of data how he
managed it they did not wait for a clause
they did not wait for google cloud
platform to have customers and to
deliver large volumes of data
nevertheless how was it before the
customer be to be wanted for example a
mapping of  france place an
order with airbus and
airbus make disks available a
storage bay, for example,
the satellite images are copied to this on this
medium and sent via a broker
directly to the customer who will
copy this information to him  there on its
information system it has been working very
well for years, however the
market changes more and more as soon as
we talk about digital start-ups
what customers wanted to see  were to
access the deal and fresh this canton
copies images that we send them by
broker and that we then copy them we do
not have the image of the day before and a
delta which can be a few days a
few months or even more  what
their customers were looking for more and more
is to say but you have the images
I would like to have an api or
something where I can directly
connect and use your data
so they thought about building this
platform for changes in stake
available to give it and how to
store their 30 years of history and
above all how to have more and more
customers who will connect to a
common platform to
fetch images it's not at all the same
problem of copying games on  a
storage bay and I send it to our
customers
so that's why they evaluated
their ability to do it at home in
their datacenter with their technology
and quickly realized that it is
economically  It was not necessarily
easy or technically and so
they naturally redirected themselves to the
cloud and luckily [ __ ] galetas
platform so this is exactly the type
of use case that is new or a
transformation of the business of a
company that  fact that we have to manage
new technical issues
large volumes of data
performance and latency
I was talking about
technology earlier storage is not new it's
been a few years since that but
we have  started overall we talk about
her being daring what was it was
just disk this ability to connect
disk directly to a machine it
works she also once again
very very well it was not very very
flexible so for that  ago we
invented systems like dussane du nas which
consisted if I put it simply it
added a network layer between the
processing part and the storage part
and that brought a lot of flexibility and
also new professions and we are
now talking about storage objects why I
'm talking about all this it's as soon as we
talk about the cloud the cloud is a
mature solution for hosting business applications
or workloads that means
that we  google
we must have this type of
technology or in any case the equivalent
of this type of technology if you
want to put your
e-commerce site your rp your
business application directly there are dependencies
on this type of technology dating  on
your applications
so we have to do it so we are going to
offer persistent disk from the ssd of the
local ssd directly from the disk connected
to the machine and with a basic principle
is that the separation of the with the
network
is really native  in our different
tools there I'm talking about disks so far
at the database level it's
pretty much the same story I was
lucky enough to know the old world
so roughly eastwards leftwards
so  where database is equal
relational databases a large
database a hotel
I transform the data and
then load it into a data warehouse
I make data marts and I manage
cubes you should know that there too it is
a technology fault  which works
very well which works very well for
an erp and as soon as we talk about terra or
tea or peta at tc something a
type of technology we reach its
limits
you have perhaps seen it with the
presentation of my
colleague earlier so since 2004 and 2006 I
won't go into the debate but it
doesn't matter there have been new
technologies, among other things hadoop that we
co-founded with the yahoo company
to be able to do
parallel processing, that's  also since that
time when technologies like
nosql appeared column-
oriented document-oriented all that to say that
if there are all these technologies it's
not just to have fun
it's if we make eye tool  if we
do transactional
if we do e-commerce globally we
won't have the same needs and we
won't have the same technologies and
that's what you are nicolas will
explain to you later how
they used these  different bricks
to set them to music and build their
solution oh no
so what I am offering you now
is detail and all the
offers with and to explain to you in case
of use
the first is almost the most  simple
google cloud storage an object is an
object storage
so it's for playing and storing
objects globally it's a very
important point in our strategy it's
that we're going to provide managed services
we're going to talk about managed services we're going to
let's talk about servers, let's not matter
globally all the sealed part all
the server part all the
machine part os it is we who will
manage it for you we will provide you with a
turnkey service that will answer
a problem the storage object  will
make it possible to create what is called a
bucket of files two plots of
documents and to download
documents
when I say document we are talking more
about log images or videos it does
only that nevertheless I was
talking about earlier  of a few terabytes of
data with airbus this is exactly the
type of solution they have
implemented another example in the video
is vimeo for example what is very
strong in this tool is that we are going to have
a single country
we are talking about the consistency of a country a
single api which nevertheless goes
varennes derivatives class for the main ones the
eco standard of line what is a
class for google cloud storage
it is globally a storage mode the
standard class this is what will
allow to have the best
performance and we will store the
data which are often access codes
line it will be the same thing
a folder d folder a file on the
other hand it is something which will be
archived and  so that will cost handsome  suddenly
much much cheaper what will
change between the two classes it will
just be the pricing or the
access mode the same api for the same product
to do hot storage archiving
or even I'm going I'm going  I will come later
from the cdn we are able to
guarantee a test there of 99.95% we
are able to make multi-regional
or regional typically a case of
use it is localized the deal and in
europe I  I can do
it I promised to illustrate the
different products with concrete cases
the first is camping storage and
delivery so it's typically
a website an e-commerce site that has a
lot of photos of the catalog
produced by  example it can be vimeo
which stores all these videos that it makes available
on its platform so it
must be able to store them
somewhere so it will store them in a
bucket with different folders
but which can be interesting with
google cloud storage  it's up to you  r
hot data very often used so
in a standard class but why
not store old videos so
online the archiving part
is the same api and we even provide a
tool called lifecycle management
thank you thank you Lyonnais and therefore which allows
finally automatically
switching from one class to another
without you and laughing and having nothing to do
typically I store in the form of data
leïto but log and why not after 90
days it goes into the archiving class
and there the coc  div and is much less
a small tool that is put in front of gcs
very often as soon as we want
performance and we want to deliver
video or image content it's a cdn
it exists on the winter market
hungry provider  from cd n like face lee like
akamai so we are obviously compatible
with this type of tool but we
now have our own tool
called claude cdn just by simple
configuration directly you use
our entire network to  our
presence servers second case of very
classic use of google cloud storage
is backup and disaster recovery for
that we will rely on a
very rich ecosystem of partners who will be
able to manage the different phases
of the cycle of  life of the data
the first thing is the ingestion part as
soon as we want to
ingest the data and we go to google cloud
storage depending on the volume it can be
interesting to compress it typically
so there we will work with people
like  inspira which are compatible with
our offer once we have made this
link possibly me from the network between
the two we are we have partners
like vim
for example or like veritas which
allows directly to copy the vm on
premise to the
google cloud platform  even to
restart them in the event of two breakdowns and to
do failover and the last very
used case these archiving more and
more companies no longer want to have to
manage their archiving  age their back up at
home because it takes space
there are related operations and there is a
certain cost so google cloud storage that
online is perfect for that we have
partnerships with netapp or emc for
example which allows direct dumping
give it to google cloud
storage
we have seen the object storage second part
we are now going to move on to the world of
the database and there it is very very
simple cloud sql provided
either mysql or postgressql it's up to
you  choose and the basic principle
it's always a service manager
ie it's google vote db to you
don't have wes installation but
you also don't have
mysql c installations  it's not you who are going to pass
the security patches it's not you
who are going to do the optimization it's
google who want to do it for you you
're going to create tables you
're going to load them your data you're going to do
sql queries
but at the  unless we provide a module
that allows  to make just a
database with an application we still
go a little further we are able to
build highly available solutions from yesteryear
so in a few
clicks we are able to manufacture
replicas for example or to do
failover and  to have tests there of
the order of 99 95% of
e-merchants
is an example but e-merchants
are very fond of this type of
technology because they use
frameworks like drupal for example
like hybris which often relies  on
relational databases
in our case if we used a
front-end barely jean helmet barely jean
it's our platform pass to this
service
overall you develop in a
language that you'll choose go php
python do a big zip and you  deploy
this at google is automatically its
basin and so it's perfect for
making mobile it's perfect for making
gaming applications it's perfect
for doing e-commerce
that's very  s well nevertheless there is no
data storage I will come back
to this later but well in our case
there is no data storage so that
we used in this
cloud architecture sql as a classic relational database
big advantage of cloud  sql mysql or
postgresql is failover key where
replicas to we are able to
loads and the production
part the analytical part to connect
tools like it loads this table or
looker directly on the analytical that
was for the relational part
that  we say is it even if it's
a bit
of a misnomer the second world we talked about nosql
so google cloud data store it's our
document-oriented nosql database I don't know
if you know google cloud data
store but it  you should know that for the
record it is our first
tool our first product google times
two platforms it is the
nosql database which was associated with our
because their name is barely jean
it's do  nc a
document-oriented database that scales
automatically again no instance no
machine you create entities you
create you define your indexes and it will
support our growth that's
why people in gaming are very
fond of it  that we can start small and
go fast and get bigger the
pricing that will change we will be sure
of the pricing for reading,
writing and storage we
support transactions with data store and
just to see players talk about
scalability I  can tell you what
you want nevertheless these
main client snapshots which have their
database from ron clark datastore only in
terms of elasticity deschênes
think it's a good one i've been talking about
cloud gaming for a while now so  here an
interesting brick not that we have put
borders and we have put a
fairly classic ken debate a brick that seems
interesting to me is networking it's the
load balancers that we have put in fr  ontal there
too we don't talk about it much but as soon as we
talk about the cloud we're going to talk about network
loadbalancer is a global service
you create you define your ip you
create it's your network loadbalancer
there's no need to do any
interzone replication to make vpn
interview all that these natives it is a
global service and it is he who will be
responsible for distributing the load here on
a framework based on containers the
database as you can
see there are some  that one there is no replica
ah there is no architecture there is nothing to
manage there is no offer it's
called cloud data store
big advantage as there is only one you
are  capable of doing analytics
and having the ten fronts typed directly
on the same and unique baas so
we really start from simplicity
that you may have seen it this morning
I talked about relational sql and I
talked about nosql the don that there is a famous
theorem which was invented by an
engineer which is the cap theorem  who
says that globally it is india
it is really difficult to have
performance of profitability and
consistency there was only one and
only cloud technology spanair
allowed to make it lie those this dear
sir
so it is a technology  that we
developed in-house on which all our
google earth gmail products are based and
overall which is very simple in
appearance is at the same time very complicated
behind which relies on mechanisms
such as atomic clocks for example
to synchronize the give it is a
global distributed relational database I don't know if you have tried
to make architectures and
clusters based on mysql postgres and/
or other vendor technologies it
's something that is not necessarily
easy to manage
there like  you may have seen it in
the demo again you create your
table you create you load your
data and after it's simple sql
so here we are on a use case
rather applications says michel
critical here in the supply chain
globally we have suppliers we
have customers and all that must access a
single system to have a
moment you are really the right up-
to-date data on stocks
how to do that  there is n
possible technology n architecture it is more or
less complicated to implement more
or less complicated administered with
claude scanner it becomes really very
easy if you want to
do analytics here again it
is something that is  completely
scalable so all you have to do is
tender them
we're going to come back to the world of nosql
beat them'all don't know if the times
series is something that
speaks
to you so it's a nosql base once
again manager says  analytics perfect as soon as
you want to do times series so
having a notion of time and a lot
of reading writing we are of the order of
a millisecond anton access as soon as you
want a lot of reading and  writing
with very little latency
it is the ideal product for that
the typical used case that haiti you
have millions and millions of
devices or two probes that connect
and which renders we see millions and
millions of information  every
millisecond every second
it depends on the systems in this
architecture what we started to
put on the front end is a tool
called pub seube people it's just
a big tip it's a message broker
so him  it will load it's an api
and those responsible for collecting all these
events that come from all
device disputes
you are able to have a few
posts per second up to
millions of posts per second
that's typically what spotify
use to collect all the
logs that come from all the
users and then you will
choose if they wanted to do beh
or streaming the data proc or the data
flow depending on how you want to manage your
data pape line  the purpose is of
this data once trial it is
once aggregated will have to put them
somewhere with i have you n is
once again a lot of ayo and low
latency beat them'all is perfect for
that there  lives khoueiry who hide
on the slide at the end why because
beat them'all sedunois sql
it's an hbase interface and that's a
very important point
it's the perfect example of the
google strategy a
compatible open technology  apparently open source standard
with an internal technology
underneath so it's a common hbase api
that means that very easily you
are able to leave from google
or go to google by passing from a
cassandra oudin hbase because it  is there
even in country nevertheless it remains a
hbase api if you want to make the year
hrithik if they wanted to make the table
it shows you this sql dimension you
know that big three and beat them'all
are able to connect
it  is to say that at the end of  count two
big three I'm going to go type my
beat'em all transparently and
put my
tools dashboarding dataviz nation of data
visualization as a table and the
last little victory and it's a
data warehouse solution you may have it  seen
with the clement assignment and I have a
client who is all squares who
just says baby cauris and justin data
warehouse but it works it's no
machine no server you create your
dataset you create your tables you
load your data c  is a
column-oriented database why
we invented it why we use it on a
daily basis it is the database that was
developed for us internally to collect
all our logs that come from all
the different machines from all our
different products all engineers at
google
ac it's a product called dremel
which initial project and bikkuri the
commercial project accesses drebel in sql to
go find the right data and
answer their question
we are talking about scalability we are talking about a
few gigas up to a few
terabytes of data and françois de la
redoute this morning was a very good
example is the same with an
impressive execution speed a few
terabytes in a few seconds why is
that because there are  a basic mechanism
which consists of separating the
processing part from the data storage part
and this is the key principle that
allows it to have this type of performance there
are two use cases that are rarely discussed
in be crisis and  sharing there
is this notion of dataset and with a simple
click I can share it with a user
as I do in google drive all
the other customers who use big
willie democratize access to give it
thanks to this sharing feature
the second is  this ability
to stream have done more than just
water loading every night we
are able to stream and give it
directly in big one
where are you at from a quick talk  er
but a case of example the logging morning
there were limougeauds who
testified dailymotion uses that to
collect all the logs which come from
tracker such as google analytics but
also their own aggregated tracker
give it and make analytics the
company ty  in montpellier for example
does exactly the same principle all
the data management is collected
in a pub then dumped after
processing in a big willie so
always this notion of log when I
say loeb it can be an event it can
be a csv but c  is really
appropriate this type of use is
more and more customers are using it as a
simple data warehouse and finally
I told you about lots of products full
of logos we like the blue logos
at google and I  just wanted to
end my presentation with this
summary
overall I told you n used
cases several used cases that have no
solution or universal technology
that's why there is  a lot of
solutions in open source but it's
the same thing with google cloud platform
we are able to do storage in
memory
no we're going to talk about themselves cash to
do data warehouse with big three
but we are able  after doing
more classic relational mysql offers
non-relational or even
storage object and generally what is
needed what I would like
you to remember from this slide is that
there is no  universal solution these
different bricks that you will
assemble they are completely
integrated into the gcp platform to
set to music and build our
solution is what I propose to you
is to hand over control now to
nicolas auger figures data officer of
the company then  lee bird who had
the opportunity to move from a
pure open source bundle strategy to
managed services and who will explain to you the
advantage of each solution
thank you very much
so I am neither cologer therefore I am the
head of  status officer at early birds
for more than a year now so
early birds is a start up created
since 2012 we are today about
twenty employees so we
offer a content personalization solution
so I will come back by  the
continuation on what it is even if we have
focused a lot on the
French market today we are deployed
in more than 15 countries and we manage to see
for more than two years a growth
of 15% per month  so which is not
without causing some technical challenges
and therefore very fresh news since
the date of September 2017 we have just
raised 5 million euros so which will
allow us to
develop it even further
so therefore a solution  personnel
and personalization what
is it it's very simple you are a fan of
hard rock
you go to the site of one of our
fnac clients for example and the
pages all the pages of the site in  made
are personalized and range  you push
content as a priority according to
your passions, so what interests you,
for example, the latest hard rock cds
or content that will appeal to all
customers who have more or less the same
passions, so to do all that
concretely, we have  need data so
data today we look like it in two
ways it's an online way so in
fact we are going we are going to deploy trackers
on the on the site of our customers, that is
to say that concretely at  each
time a user
performs an action on the site, in fact, we
will record it, i.e. each
time he looks at an article file,
leave a comment on an article m
I like j  don't like to click on a button
the master in the cowardly basket so
on in fact we will record it we will
also manage the deal and offline
so that makes for example store sales
if the customer is deployed
online and in  store it will also be
crm type data
st to say the customer knowledge
so concretely it will be his age his
place of residence his sex
possibly two pieces of information to link
to the wishes of the customer and therefore all that
we will put it in imp August of our
machine learning algorithms and therefore
are  algorithms
so we will see from the classification
of regression or even clustering the purpose
of these algorithms helps to
actually look for patterns
between interaction in fact between
users on the one hand and therefore
products and content  on the other hand so
that is to say that concretely two
users who have more or less the same
journey
so that is to say it is not just to
say that they will have visited more or less
the same exits from our eyelashes  on
how to navigate on the on the site and
on the client's applications in fact
we are going to bring them together by one according to
the same the same pattern of two products
for example of content which are
consulted in the same way by the  same
type of customers will also be approached
so that's our algorithms and
once that's going the same reel in fact it's
going to provide us with models that will
actually allow us to provide
content personalization so the goal
of our  solution in fact is to be
able to personalize the content
on all the pages,
that is to say that concretely if we
walk for example on the site on the
homepage of the fnac for example we
therefore it is a place where usually
so we're going to find it may be the
new products the trendy products the
sales
so concretely the goal in fact is
to stay in this spirit but
while personalizing greenhouse content
while bringing up as much content as possible as much
as possible we negotiated  its
possible with the customer's appetites
we will also be able to
customize the sorting of the list page,
i.e. concretely the results
of the search pages
so in fact when you  you enter when
you fill out a dialog box
to do research while
if you are looking for a microwave
for example you will specify some
brands its dimensions maybe its
color and a range of free for example
so in fact the goal really knew  to
continue to provide you with these
results, but each user
actually has a result that is different
according to them according to their
appetites and the goal obviously being
to go back to the first page and
even at the top of the products that
are the most likely
to interest him therefore and also therefore more
classically therefore in the article sheet
where for example we will have
products so that they are really
consulted by the same users at the
time when they are on the same point
on the  site
we will also see in the summary baskets,
for example,
we will come and push products that
are likely to interest and which
naturally complement  ent the
basket of other other other
users who are sticking to
similar behavior
so concretely to go into a little
more detail would be that I talk a
lot about product recommendations
but our solution is not limited
to that at all
so already it  it's true that on the
examples I presented we were talking
more about websites and we are also
deployed therefore on mobile sites on
mobile applications we can also
be deployed in a certain way on
two on stores  physical or
on advertising on external sites
like on facebook for example where we
go there again we will be able
to personalize the content so we were talking
about product recommendations this one about
the redesign of content so we have for
example  a customer who recommends
beauty institute services we
see drinking recommending claims
within the institutes we will be able to
offer the institutes themselves we
have  other customers who are part of the
private sale or the flash sale
so there the idea is going to be to be able to
recommend either a sale in itself or
introduced in a sale or a brand
and so on
I said  a moment ago we
personalize the
therefore the results of the research phase
therefore the sorting of washing lists the advantage
is that we can therefore we can either do
the management of the research internally
with us if however the customer is
using an external search engine
is also possible so we have
n't met a lot of customers who are
using the algo lia search engine
and we are quite capable of
providing this personalization service
even on a  on a search system
is outsourced other use cases
so we can make recommendations
there it was in fact we can serve
serve emails so without really
personalizing its austere especially the
customer catalog so on customers
of our customers
we will be able to
send them emails which will all be
different to best fit their
appetite we also go to shrink if a
customer prints three
different physical catalogs we will be able to
tell them in fact for each customer
which one  of the three we will have to
send to obtain the
best the best match the
best possible performance
so in terms of growth the graph
speaks for itself
so we have a growth that is very
significant and very stable
or the particularity of their freedom
that  'we mainly focused and
on large accounts
we serve the idea is that we do not have
many accounts but about sixty
all the same but which are
mainly the biggest French
e-merchants
so today  today we are refining ac and darty
we at redoubt we had to lacoste which is
very internationalized we had to
crossroads who trusted us and
it continues and suddenly in the idea o  where we
must we must aggregate all of
their traffic
it still represents a certain
volume so it presents a lot of
data to manage so in terms
of architecture in fact I will
present to you the different stages of
setting up this  architecture because
we weren't always able to
manage today's volumetrics so
so initially
the architecture was actually quite simple so
we had a console and an api so it was
developed in a jet set that ran on
on compute engine instances
from google so already at the time we
were sure of the heart of the club from
google we had the only
mung db database so in fact it was
the base that stored all our  so
it covers the activities, that is to say
the interactions between the users
and
the products or the content it covered
the information on the items so the
shooting of the product repositories bags
opened all the information on the
pr  of these all our configurations and we
had in third in third element
of the technical stac so the oryx layer
so in fact which is a technology
so does a lot of things
mainly that it was able to
serve the recommendation of products
in real time and c  is a solution which
also managed the calculation of the models including
via a cluster which makes the manager
manager itself the real time management
with the layer the casca layer for
the management of the messages
so here is in fact it is a stat which
on the  on paper works well
the problem is that in fact very
quickly as the return of customers decreases it
starts to be very limited years it
started to be more and more
difficult if only  to
record activities in real time and it
quickly became in fact completely
impossible salaries in fact we were
not able in real time to insert
all the deals
and coaches quickly enough  e it serves the aggregation
of all the activities that came from
all these sites is therefore obviously we
understand that if it takes more than 24
hours in fact to process 24 hours of
data or to insert the data
of one day and that  quickly becomes
impossible so at this stage there in fact
we relocated part of the deal
is so it was mainly the deal
and activity since it is the one that
is the most voluminous with us
and suddenly we relocated in a  base
which is called cassandra that a
column-oriented nosql base which was
which was still running on
confused instances of greenhouse instances that we
that we managed ourselves the big
advantage is that it also made it possible to
get our heads out of  water since in
fact we have it we were again able
to record weight in real time all
the data the downside
is that it was a bass which is
not necessarily very easy to manage we
would be that at the time  early bird was
much smaller so there were also
not
many engineers to be able to manage that and it
took a relatively long time
to manage this base there and
in terms of daliot so on the
calculations of  output so when we
wanted to run our
machine learning calculations
so we had a bandwidth that
was a little low and suddenly
it's true that it was a little long so
they were born followed in fact a phase  a
little transitory or in fact we started
to leave the product at risk so that is
to say to fights which was an
open source solution so we
hesitated a lot as time went on
we said to ourselves  that rather than what I said is
a solution
we wanted as much to do in fact
to develop ours what would
allow us to escape is exactly
our business and so we did it and it
also allows us to free ourselves from the choice
of technologies  so been bound
categorical c  is to be able to put
those we wanted in front and so
it's also a step we started to
relocate the deal is therefore also
part of the deal and navigation for
everything that is analytical, that is to
say  the follow-up of the follow-up of
the follow-up of the statistics here we are
so we are in fact on the seems to be
the current architecture so in fact this
is the architecture we have since
2010 is since the beginning of 2010 is therefore in
fact we we  a
lot of things have changed the big
change in terms of performance is
the passage of cassandra habitable
so there are two reasons for that in fact
it's that the
so it's big apple is also a
column-oriented nosql database at the same
title that cassandra there are actually two
differences, the first being
that it is based on the
age boys data model which is, as
Sébastien very rightly said earlier,
particularly suited to the management of time
series and time
series  in fact it is  exactly
what we are handling since as soon as we
actually store an interaction between a
user and a and content or and
in fact introduces it is a time
series we know it is indexed by
a parent by intermittent and the other
the  other benefits in fact it is made on
the fact that the base is completely
manager so the base being completely
managed by google in fact we
found ourselves no longer having any
maintenance operation on it it
works it worked all the time and that
allowed us to free up a lot of
time on this point so then the
layer four cases which were integrated
into the brix system so was naturally
passed on to people only holds an equivalent
of a message manager who
but who himself is a manager  at the level
of calculations therefore serves as
data processing we are therefore we use data
flow and data proc so dataflow it will
be that it will allow us to
make hotel, that is to say therefore in fact we
recover  the deal and our customers
we transform it a little so in order
to put them in the right format and
then we Serbian it in our
different databases and above all
the processing only gave a little more
complex we use date approach so
in fact  its poor
data processing it covers everything that is
algorithms, machine learning in
particular and we also use the
cloud storage solution so
blob-oriented storage management we are talking about and Sébastien later
so what allows us  to
store to learn all the
inputs of our customers it allows to
store intermediate calculations or
even the models of machine learning
once they are calculated we
cerialize them directly above and we
always have to dress it the analysis  x there
the
bidegorry solution therefore which provides an sql engine
on top which allows to query very
quickly and very easily
all the necessary data and
which allows us to per  it is then up to us in
our console to display a whole bunch of
metrics which allows us to know where
if the algorithms are behaving well
so I did not say them earlier
actually may
be another way of also seeing if our
algorithms does not behave well it is
in the console in fact since we have these
analytical tools this in fact we will
allow we will be able in fact to
set up tests, that is to
say to cut a  part of
our customers' traffic to test different
strategies in parallel to be able to see
and even test different
configurations strategy is to be able to
see which one behaves best
so here we go then on the stac concludes
so we always have our systems on
machines that don't  are who are not
necessarily managers and the advantage is
that we arrive today at the stopover is
automatically these arts according to the
traffic in fact we will be able to
modulate the number of nodes
horizontally for av  always have
a charge a charge that is contained
in a party is always the most suitable cost
possible the in fact all
of our stacks are stored on
google
it also allows you to benefit it's a
bit of the icing on the cake
tools for logging and
monitoring tools for google machines so
early bird in a few figures
so today we display about 9
million recommendations per day
which corresponds to about 700
million calls paid by me I  say
on average since depending on
the month we have very very strong
disparities in arms trafficking if we
look at the month of December 2016 in
fact we have counted more than 3
billion calls for a reason that
is quite simple  it's that
e-merchants, so they represent a
large part of our clientele, are
in fact enormously solicited just
before the Christmas period
so obviously thanks to your stack
to this scalability in fact we are
able in fact to adapt the traffic is
to be able to always provide a service
therefore in good conditions so in
terms of response time today
we are around 30 5 milliseconds
on average in terms of sl therefore there is
availability suddenly we
mainly uses google tools which we
manage to reach in fact the same
levels of stability as google,
i.e. today we measure
availability at around 99 99% and we have
an abject 1 ap of kz2 since 99 %
that is to say the number of
we have less than one percent of the requests
in fact that they respond under which
respond above 150 milliseconds
than in fact which is the time beyond
which we consider that c  is more
instantaneous so a quick conclusion
on this architecture so
more of this architecture do
more first is scalability
so there today we are perfectly
capable and very fortunately of managing
all the traffic and all the calculations of
all our customers and we are completely
confident about being able to manage
all the data that will arrive with the
new customers who are going
to trust us and we know that this type
of architecture works well because
it is  also what these people have using
spotify which manages which manages a lot
more data than us very important point
it is the ease of migration from
in the google manager tools
so Sébastien said it earlier if
we take the  case of bic theme ''the for
example the country for therefore the customer in
fact to consult the date at
danville table it is the same as
that of app hh bays so it is APIs that
we know well and  5.6 today we
are already dos reis bays tuque the pay is
the same in fact we can we can use
the meuse manager google in fact change
the code
which also means that if we
want to leave google in fact since  since
we don't have any in our
code of adherence to googl technologies  and
we can get in and out very easily
so that gives us a
certain flexibility which is very
interesting
another point that I
mentioned earlier the absence of development,
that is to say that in fact today  'today,
database maintenance system administration
tasks represent almost nothing or
even nothing at all in the time of
our
engineers, which allows us today to
devote ourselves
exclusively to what  we know
how to do so with customization and
finally if it's the level of performance
so serves the response times which
are extremely low on the on
all the stac the astag google and the
downtime which is almost zero we don't  we've had
almost no problems since
we've been at google and it's always
very, very short so here's to end
if some of you in the room
have ideas to improve us further they
think they can do better
we invite you  see you  nir join us
since we have four some votes were
here thank you thank you Nicolas